das ist ein Film über die wahren Helden
am Mount Everest der mit 8.850 Metern
höchsten Berg der Welt
die schadpass sie ermöglichen den
westlichen Bergsteigern den Traum vom
Gipfel tragen ihre Lasten und bereiten
ihnen den Weg
unsere Helden sind Norbu ein 29-jähriger
Sherpa aus Kathmandu am Anfang seiner
Karriere
für mich geht es nicht nur ums Geld ich
wollte schon immer mal auf dem Gipfel
stehen
[Musik]
mit 42 Jahren eine Legende er stand 13
Mal auf dem Gipfel des Everest
mit dem Einkommen einer Expedition
ernähre ich meine Familie ein ganzes
Jahr lang deshalb muss ich als schärfer
arbeiten
[Musik]
dieser Film zeigt das Leben der Sherpas
und ihre Arbeit am Everest
[Musik]
es ist die Geschichte über ihren
verdienten Gipfelerfolg es ist aber auch
ein Film überleben und Tod der zeigt wie
sich die Sherpas für das Leben ihrer
Kunden aufopfern und sich dadurch selber
in Todesgefahr bringen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist Ende März im kleinen Dörfchen
Tamo auf
3.490 Meter die Schapers sind ein
Volksstamm der vor 500 Jahren von Tibet
nach Nepal gezogen ist sie sprechen
einen tibetischen Dialekt leben von der
Landwirtschaft haben aber schnell
begriffen dass mit westlichen
Expeditionen mehr Geld zu verdienen ist
so auch long dodgy der seiner Frau auf
dem Feld hilft
[Musik]
sein Vater starb bereits früh
ich weiß wenig von meinem Vater
er war auch im Trekking Business tätig
meine Mutter blieb daheim und erledigte
die Hausarbeit
wir hatten auch Jagd die wir im Sommer
auf die Hochweiden brachten und im
Winter bei uns hielten meine Mutter
verkaufte Butter und
joghurty der lange Doggy hat es dank
seiner Stärke und seiner Körpergröße
weit gebracht
[Musik]
seine 13 Everest Erfolge beeindrucken
sowohl den buddhistischen Lama wie auch
die einfachen Bauern
die buddhistische Religion spielt im
Leben der scherpers eine große Rolle so
bekommt der Lama eine kleine Gabe und
einen Glücksschein
Doji lebt mit seiner Frau passantiki in
seinem Elternhaus
mit dem Geld aus den Expeditionen
schicken sie ihre beiden Töchter nach
Kathmandu in die Schule
sie hoffen dass ihre Kinder dadurch ein
besseres Leben führen ja vielleicht
sogar ins Ausland ziehen können
longodgy leidet darunter dass er selbst
keine Schulbildung bekommt er musste
früh Verantwortung für die Familie
übernehmen
es gab viele Gründe warum ich nicht
studieren konnte
meine Brüder gingen in die Schule ich
nicht
ich musste das viehüten
aber der
älteste Bruder meine zwei jüngeren
Brüder nach Kathmandu mit und ich blieb
allein zu Hause
dann würde ich Träger für verschiedene
trekkinggruppen und lernte Leute kennen
so gewann ich Erfahrungen in diesem
Beruf und da ich stark und schlau war
habe ich auch meine Arbeit gut
verrichtet
die meisten Leute haben mich gerne
angestellt
seine beiden Brüder leben heute dank
ihrer Ausbildung in Amerika
longodgy blieb das einfache Leben von
Tamo hier feiert die
Hochzeitsgesellschaft seiner Nichte in
seinem Haus
[Applaus]
durch das Bergsteigen erreichte deutsche
Berühmtheit und Wohlstand
[Applaus]
fatmandou die hektische Hauptstadt
Nepals mit über 1,2 Millionen Einwohnern
ist sie das Zentrum des Landes es ist
ein Schmelztiegel vieler Kulturen und
Religionen hier befindet sich die größte
buddhistische Stupa Nepals der
bodnat-tempel
Norbu Sherpa lebt in Kathmandu als Kind
wurde er von seiner Familie zu einer
Tante nach Darjeeling in Indien
geschickt wo er eine gute Ausbildung
bekam er versuchte im Ausland einen Job
zu ergattern doch er wurde Opfer einer
Schlepperbande verlor sein Geld und
landete wieder in Kathmandu
hier von der schließlich einen Job im
Büro eine trekking-agentur die mit dem
Schweizer Bergführer karikobler
zusammenarbeitet
als wenn man im Dorf bleibt
in Kathmandu hat man Zugang zu Computern
und so viele Kontakte zu Ausländer
die Büroarbeit wurde ihm aber bald zu
langweilig auf sein Drängen hin bekam er
die Chance auf Expeditionen mitzugehen
zuerst als Küchenjunge dann als
Hochträger als sogenannter climing
Sherpa
climbing sharpers die in Kathmandu Leben
haben gute Möglichkeiten Geld zu
verdienen und sich eine bessere Zukunft
aufzubauen
möchte nicht dein Leben lang diesen
gefährlichen und anstrengenden Job als
climbing-schärfer ausüben sondern später
den Ruhm das Geld und seine Kontakte
nutzen um sich weiter zu entwickeln
in Long Dirty South findet wie vor jeder
Expedition eine feierliche Zeremonie
eine sogenannte Botschaft
die Mönche kommen aus dem benachbarten
buddhistischen Kloster
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ohne eine solche Putscher würde longodgy
nie zum Everest gehen den die Sherpas
nennen
für uns wir beten zu ihr bevor wir
aufsteigen wir bieten sie um Erlaubnis
und beten dass niemandem etwas passiert
und wieder einmal packt long Doggy
seinen Rucksack für die nächsten zwei
Monate alles Gute und Kira heilt zurück
das wünsche ich dir auch überarbeite
dich nicht jetzt gehe ich pass auf dich
auf
long dirtys Frau ist von nun an zwei
Monate allein
wenn das Wetter schlecht ist mache ich
mir Sorgen und wenn Leute vorbeikommen
will ich immer wissen ob Sie Neuigkeiten
von Deutsche haben
wenn mir jemand nicht antwortet
befürchte ich stets dass er mir
irgendwelche schlechten Nachrichten
vorenthalten will
[Musik]
mir geht es erst wieder gut wenn er
zurück ist
[Musik]
es ist Ende März 2008 im Flughafen von
Kathmandu ist der Schweizer Bergführer
karikobler mit seinen
expeditionsteilnehmern gelandet
[Musik]
longodgy und andere sharepas erwarten
ihn
karikobler führt seit acht Jahren
Expeditionen zum Everest durch er selber
stand bereits dreimal auf den Gipfel
er wird von 9 expeditionsmitgliedern
begleitet
[Musik]
jeder hat 40.000 Franken bezahlt um sich
seinen Traum vom Everest durch Curry und
seine Organisation erfüllen zu lassen
die Zeit um sich auch in Kathmandu von
seiner Familie zu verabschieden er
trifft Sie im Haus seiner Schwester
seine Töchter gehen hier zur Schule die
jüngere ist nur die Zähne in einem
Kloster und die ältere besucht eine
Privatschule
ich bin Studentin wenn mich der Lehrer
in der Schule fragt was mein Vater mache
dann sage ich dass er Bergsteiger sei
wenn mein Vater den Gipfel bezwingt bin
ich glücklich wenn ich den Beruf meines
Vaters beschreibe fühle ich mich stolz
jeden Morgen bete ich zu Gott dass mein
Vater Erfolg hat und heil nach Hause
kommt
an den Abschied können sie sich nicht
gewöhnen zu groß ist die Angst dass der
Vater einmal nicht mehr zurückkehren
könnte
[Musik]
am Fuße des Everest auf
5.340 Meter treffen unterdessen die
ersten Schapers ein es ist eine
besondere Gruppe die hier den Gletscher
betritt
an niemand Sherpa und seine
eisballdoktoren
ihr Arbeitsplatz ist der gewaltige
scheinbar unüberwindbare kumbu als Fall
das Tor zum Everest diese Schapers
werden zwischen diesen Eistürmen den Weg
für die Expeditionen vorbereiten
ausgerüstet mit Leitern und Seilen
machen sie sich auf in das Eislabyrinth
den Namen eisfalldoktoren bekamen sie
von zwei Everest Veteranen die sie einst
bei ihrer Arbeit beobachtet hatten
sie sahen zu wie wir arbeiteten wir
legen die Leitern Drehen an den
Eisschrauben schlagen mit dem eishammer
zu und fixieren die Seile vielleicht
hielten sie das für Arbeit von Doktoren
zuerst nannte man uns jedenfalls
eisfallarbeiter aber dann sagten alle
das sind eisfalldoktoren
bevor ein westlicher Bergsteiger je
einen Fuß in den Eisfall setzt beginnen
diese scherpers ihre gefährliche Arbeit
sie verlegen und verankern Seile und
Leitern der Eisfall bewegt sich je nach
Schätzung zwischen 30 cm und einem Meter
pro Tag
der Eisfall ist wie Popcorn oben bedeckt
von Schnee und unten offen
an verschiedenen Stellen kann man dabei
echoähnliche Geräusche hören und dann
weiß man dass hier in der nächsten Tagen
das Eis brechen wird
am Nima kennt den Eisfall wie kein
Zweiter
seit 1975 sucht er mit seinem Team jedes
Jahr einen neuen Weg zwischen den Haus
hohen gletschertürmen
die Expedition von carica befindet sich
im Anflug auf Flugplan
[Musik]
das Dorf auf
2860 Metern ist Ausgangspunkt jeder
Everest Expedition
auch für die beiden walliser-teilnehmer
und Bergführer Patricks Brunn und
Meinrad
[Musik]
sicher
es ist Catrice
expeditionsberichte
vorwärts und rückwärts-
das ist irgendwie Gedanken und jetzt so
eine letzte zwei Jahre plötzlich das ist
wirklich kristallisiert wieso nicht
im südpoliger
Knaller für mich am Fuße des Everest im
Eisfall geht die Arbeit der
ausfalldoktoren derweil weiter am Nima
sucht eine sichere Route
vorsichtig tastet er sich voran denn es
besteht die Gefahr in eine verdeckte
Gletscherspalte zu stürzen
nein nicht auf dieser Seite es ist
gefährlich
die andere Seite ist besser auch wenn
sie länger ist
eine Leiter genügt dort hier müssen wir
fünf zusammenbinden
rund 55 bis 60 Leiter und 3.500 Meter
Seil werden sie in den nächsten Tagen
verlegen
die gefährliche Arbeit hinterlässt
allerdings Spuren selbst in der Nacht
schreckt Amina immer wieder auf und
träumt vom maiswald
im Basislager auf 5.340 Metern Treffen
der waljax und die Träger mit dem
Material für die verschiedenen
Expeditionen ein nicht weniger als 41
werden erwartet die schärpers von
karikobeles Expedition sind damit
beschäftigt einen guten Lagerplatz im
Eis heraus zu hacken
[Applaus]
die Expeditionsteilnehmer nähern sich
derweil Schritt für Schritt dem Basecamp
und tauchen in die Kultur der Sherpas
ein intence auf 3.860 Metern liegt das
wichtigste buddhistische Kloster des
Thales
zweimal wurde das Kloster durch
Katastrophen zerstört und wieder
aufgebaut
Zeit für jeden Bergsteiger einen Moment
inne zu halten
das Kloster ist einmal total
niedergebrannt heizt ihr deshalb im
Winter nicht mehr
aber dann ist es sehr kalt im Winter
ja
aber ihr lebt tief unten und wir hoch
oben unser Blut ist sehr stark
ich bin ein junger Mann
ich muss jetzt rein danach können wir
weitersprechen
-20 Grad
[Musik]
im Basislager herrscht inzwischen
Hochbetrieb
Expeditionsleiter karikobler ist
eingetroffen und kontrolliert die
Aufbauarbeiten
zwischen den Eisbrocken platzieren die
Sherpas mehrere große Zelte wie hier das
materialzelt
und auch die gefährliche Arbeit im
Eisfall geht voran
mit mehr Kraft ja komm mit mehr Kraft
[Musik]
sie haben die gefährlichste Stelle im
Eishalle erreicht man nennt sie den Damm
5 Leitern haben sie zusammengebunden um
voranzukommen
dort hinaufziehen wenn ihr sie
zusammengebunden habt
dahinter hat sein großes Loch
geh hoch und schau wie groß ist
Spalte sehr groß
und das wissen wir wenn wir den Rand
erreicht haben wenn es dort nicht
weitergeht müssen wir alle Sachen
mitnehmen und woanders einen Weg suchen
bald schon werden hunderte von
Bergsteigern über diese Leitern steigen
die von Amina und seinem Team verlegt
wurden
und ohne die die meisten Everest
Aspiranten nie eine Chance auf den
Gipfel hätten
noch ist der Gipfel auch für die
Schweizer Bergsteiger nur ein Traum
gemeinsam mit Narbe und Dodge kommen sie
dem Basislager immer näher auf ihrem Weg
stoßen sie auf einen Ort der Ihnen die
Gefahren ihres Traumes vor Augen führt
Leben und Tod liegen am Everest nahe
beieinander
davon zeugen in dougla diese steinernen
Gedenkstätten
sie erinnern an all die Menschen die am
Everest ihr Leben gelassen haben
über 200 Tote hat der Everest bis jetzt
gefordert darunter viele westliche
Bergsteiger aber auch scherpass
und auch von dieser Expedition wird
einer nicht mehr zurückkehren
oder immer wieder zur Vorsicht weil man
selber eigentlich ein gleiches Schicksal
erleben könnte oder eben nicht mehr
erleben könnte Johnny Golz der Tessiner
stand bereits auf sechs 8000ern
schön sehr schön
nach sieben Tagen kommen die Bergsteiger
im Basecamp an
dieses ist mittlerweile zu einer
riesigen Zeltstadt angewachsen
41 Expeditionen sind hier versammelt das
sind rund 1000 Personen Bergsteiger
sherpers und andere Helfer
allein beschäftigt 15 scherpass
the rich Big Mountain the biggest
mountain the world okay Start hier
13 Mal auf dem Everest
Angelo
er spricht deutsch
eine meiner ältesten sherpes mit dem
habe ich schon etwas bestiegen schon
eben gerade letztes Jahr tendy
hat schon viele Sachen für uns gemacht
letztes Jahr waren mit uns im Pakistan
er war letztes Jahr am sattelbahn also
ist einer unser bekanntesten zusammen
mit
Norberto gehört auch zu unseren TOP
Cracks und ich hoffe sie helfen uns da
wird uns nachher beglückwünschen können
den Everest bestimmt zu haben danke
vielmals
[Applaus]
wie hat Cari sein Team zusammengestellt
es gibt ein paar wichtige Faktoren dass
zum Beispiel immer mindestens zwei aus
der gleiche Region sind sage jetzt mal
mindestens zwei aus dem makro-region das
ist so aus
Verständnis wo sie einfach heute für sie
werden immer zweite sieht es wenn nicht
passiert dass der andere im helft und
der Münz aus der Region sie noch nicht
ob ich es muss starche haben Weg
konditionell stark die Menü gut Englisch
können
motorente anderes
in der nächsten Wochen werden die
sherpes vom Basislager aus weitere Lager
einrichten Lager 1 auf 5900 Meter
Lager 2 auf 6.400 m Lager 3 auf 7.300
Meter und Lager 4 auf 7.900 m sie werden
diese Wege rauf und runter gehen und
dabei Geld verdienen der Lohn wird
vorher im Basislager ausgehandelt Cari
Kobler bezahlt ein grundzahler von 2000
Dollar dazu kommt der Leistungslohn
je nachdem wie oft ein Sherpa in ein
Hochlager aufsteigt und wie viel er
trägt umso mehr Geld kann er verdienen
NABU der Junge sirda oder Chef der
Sherpas übersetzt die Vorschläge vom
Kari die Sherpas haben ihre eigenen
Vorstellungen es folgen
Lohnverhandlungen wie auf dem Basar
lass uns mehr Grundlohn verlangen statt
mehr Bonus
andere gruppenzahlen 2200 Dollar lasst
uns verhandeln ja wir sollten jetzt
verhandeln wie steht es mit den
Zahlungen oben wir sollten etwas mehr
verlangen für Lager 3 ins Camp 3 gehen
wir ja nur einmal oder
und so wird um den Lohn für jedes
Hochlager gefälscht okay
ihr wollt 50 ich will 40 zahlen also
sagen wir 45
alle sollen zufrieden sein
ihr und ich
ich mag es nicht wenn ihr nicht
zufrieden seid okay
45 ist okay
dann kämmt 3
C
mein letzter Preis für camp4 120
dieses harte Arbeit das weiß jeder
seid ihr einverstanden ja okay er ist
der härteste Mann
verdient für diese Expedition zwischen
4.500 und 5.500 Dollar je nach Leistung
Miteinander schaffen
und das funktioniert jetzt inzwischen
zieht auf absolut genial
sherpass wie longodgy verdienen in den
folgenden zwei Monaten und das Doppelte
Jahresziel eines Lehrers in Kathmandu
dafür leisten sie aber fast
Übermenschliches und riskieren ihr Leben
wie ist long dort sie mit den
Verhandlungen zufrieden
die Diskussionen um den Bonus waren auch
gut alle Kollegen sind zufrieden
in den nächsten zwei Monaten entsteht
eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft zwischen
Sherpas und expeditionsteilnehmern ihren
Freiraum haben die scherpers in ihrem
Küchenzelt mit eigenem Koch der nur
nepalesische Gerichte kocht wie hier
Dido ein gerstengericht
das Zelt ist Aufenthaltsraum hier wird
gegessen diskutiert und gelacht ohne
westliche Bergsteiger
[Musik]
die Expeditionsteilnehmer haben ihr
eigenes Zelt ihre eigene Küche und
angenehmen Luxus auf
5.340 Metern das Zelt ist geheizt
jeden Abend werden Sie mit einem
Drei-Gang-Menü überrascht gekocht und
serviert von der sherba Küchenmannschaft
gekocht wird nach dem Geschmack der
Gäste heute zum Beispiel Pommes frites
und Momos
[Musik]
gemeinsam ist allen das Ziel der Mount
Everest
wir respektieren den Everest als unsere
Mutter die gäbe es keinen Everest können
Sie sich vorstellen wie dann unser Leben
wäre wir sehen den Berg als ein
göttliches Symbol wir singen auch ein
Lied ich kam zu dir bitte liebe mich
wir Summen stets das Mantra um manipet
me home
am 17 April findet im Basislager die
traditionelle buddhistische Botschaft
statt dieser Tag war heißt im Kalender
der Sherpas viel Glück
Steigeisen und Pickel werden gesegnet
ein bergsteigender Lama führt durch die
Zeremonie
[Musik]
da wird
Leute stimmen
[Musik]
während der rund zweistündigen Zeremonie
ziehen die Sherpas bunte Gebetsfahnen
über das ganze Lager der Wind soll die
Gebete in alle Himmelsrichtungen tragen
und Glück bringen
[Musik]
dazu kommen irdische finanzielle
Opfergaben die der Lama bekommt wer
Glück für sich will muss auch etwas
zahlen
zum Abschluss der Puja werfen alle Mehl
in die Luft
ich fühlte mich in den letzten Tagen
nicht sehr gut
nun ist die Zeremonie endlich vorbei
jetzt ist alles in Ordnung ich bin
glücklich
ich habe einen tiefen Glauben obwohl ich
gut ausgebildet bin in Kathmandu wohne
und nicht in einem Dorf ich praktiziere
meinen Glauben auch in der Stadt
vor dem ersten Aufstieg sortieren die
Sherpas die riesige Menge von Nahrung
die sie in die einzelnen Hochlager
transportieren müssen
es ist vor allem Nahrung die leicht
verdaulich ist
jeder von euch bekommt einen Sack und
später nehmen wir noch einen zweiten
die Expeditionsteilnehmer wie Patricks
Bruhn bekommen solche Säcke in die Sie
Ihr persönliches Material packen und den
scherpers mitgeben
12 Kilo sein für jeden wir geben hier
einen zweiten Sack dazu ich wiege alles
um das genaue Gewicht zu kennen
erstes Ziel ist das Lager 1 auf 5900
Meter der Weg für Basislager durch den
Eisfall
bereit zum 3 Uhr morgens machen sich die
scherbas auf den Weg
[Musik]
das ist das Leben der schärpers was kann
man da machen
scherpers aller Expeditionen wollen
heute für Ihre Teilnehmer das Material
ins Lager 1 hinaufbringen alle Folgen
der Route welche die eisfalldoktoren
gelegt haben
[Musik]
bereits morgens um fünf Uhr kommt es zu
ersten Staus im Eisfall
der Aufstieg ist schwierig
auch für erfahrene sharpers wie Norbu
ist es nicht leicht auf über 5.500
Metern Lasten von 20 Kilo oder mehr zu
transportieren
etwas später starten die
Expeditionsteilnehmer
obwohl sie alle sehr erfahren sind und
teilweise als Bergführer in der Schweiz
arbeiten sind die Leiter der
eiswalddoktoren auch für sie eine
Mutprobe ein Fehltritt könnte fatale
Folgen haben
langsam und konzentriert bewegen sie
sich in der ungewohnten Höhe
[Musik]
nach drei Stunden erreichen die sharepas
Lager 1 auf 5.900 Metern sie stellen die
Zelte für ihre Kunden auf die eine Nacht
hier oben verbringen werden um sich zu
akklimatisieren
auf allen vier Seiten
nachdem die Sherpas die Zelte verankert
und das Material deponiert haben steigen
sie wieder ab ins Basislager um weiteres
Gepäck zu holen
auch am Nima und seine eisfalldoktoren
sind gefordert sie müssen neue Leitern
und Seile legen da sie die Eismassen
ständig bewegen und Hunderte von Leuten
zu gleichen Zeit unterwegs sind
diese verrückten Gletscherspalten
heute haben wir einen neuen Weg
ausprobiert
durch die Wärme lösen sich Lawinen die
in den eisfalldonnern
die Sherpas arbeiten die nächsten sechs
Wochen praktisch ohne Unterbruch kaum
zurück im Basislager packen sie neues
Material das sie in den nächsten Tagen
ins Lager 2 hinauftragen werden
lasst uns die Sachen aufteilen schauen
wir zuerst mal das Material der members
an dann die Eisschrauben die Seile und
die felzarten
ich liebe es zwar in den Bergen und auf
dem Gipfel zu sein aber den Anfang einer
Expedition den mag ich gar nicht
der Job sehr sehr hart mit all den
Lasten dem Zelt aufstellen das ist alles
sehr sehr hart auf
am nächsten Tag steigen die sharepas
aller Expeditionen zum ersten Mal zum
Camp 2 auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
norbo ist bereits eingetroffen um auf
dem Gletscher einen guten Platz für die
Expedition von karikobler zu reservieren
hier entsteht ein vorgeschobenes
Basislager mit allem Komfort
wie geht's
vier bis fünf Teilnehmer werden heute
hier oben schlafen kommt Jungs lasst uns
den Platz vorbereiten wir müssen
arbeiten keine Zeit zum Ausdrucken
20 Liter Kerosin das zum Kochen
gebraucht wird
die anderen Sherpas bauen ein komplettes
Küchenzelt auf
der Koch wird in den nächsten Wochen
hier oben bleiben
inzwischen trifft auch long Doggy mit
neuem Gepäck ein
fünf Schlafzelte sowie ein geräumiges
esszelt mit Tischen und Campingstühlen
richten die sherpes für die
Expeditionsmitglieder
kämpft mit der noch ungewohnten Höhe
ich habe fürchterliches Kopfweh
wenn ich mich bücke habe ich das Gefühl
zu fallen
die Küchenmannschaft sucht inzwischen im
Gletscher frisches Eis um Wasser
abzukochen
dabei stoßen sie direkt neben ihrem
Lagerplatz auf einen grausigen Fund
der Gletscher hat Leichenteile eines
Bergsteigers der vor Jahren in eine
Gletscherspalte gefallen ist freigegeben
das ist nur eine von vielen Leichen die
irgendwo am Everest verschollen sind
viele der verunglückten Bergsteiger
werden nie mehr gefunden
[Applaus]
der Tod ist Teil jeder Everest
Besteigung
für die Sherpas geht die Arbeit weiter
um bei Kräften zu bleiben gehört eine
Pause mit viel Flüssigkeit dazu
drei bis fünf Liter pro Tag sollten
getrunken werden da der Körper auf
dieser Höhe sehr viel Flüssigkeit
verliert
dann bricht long dodgy wieder auf
erklärt ins über 1000 Meter tiefer
gelegene Basecamp zurück um neue Lasten
zu holen fünf Tage lang werden die
Sherpas nun für die Teilnehmer immer
wieder Material vom Basislager ins Camp
2 hinauf transportieren
Norbu bleibt im Lager 2 und organisiert
die Transporte
erstens ein Solarladegerät zweitens zwei
große Matten drittens ein Medizinkoffer
Thema Märchen Box
währenddessen befinden sich die
Schweizer Bergsteiger im Eiswall
gemeinsam mit vielen Teilnehmern anderer
Expeditionen mit leichtem Gepäck sind
zum Camp 2 unterwegs wo einige eine
weitere Nacht zur Akklimatisation
verbringen werden
absteigende schärpers kommen in den
entgegen unerfahrene Everest Aspiranten
versperren den Weg
was alle befürchtet haben passiert es
kommt zum Stau auf über 5800 m
long dirty ist bereits wieder im
Basislager Sherpas leiden in der Höhe
genauso wie jeder andere westliche
Bergsteiger sie dürfen sich aber nicht
anmerken lassen und lächeln immer
freundlich wie lang dortji
auch wenn es weh tut man muss immer
Stehvermögen zeigen dazu sind wir
gezwungen es gibt scherpas die lassen
alle Last zurück wenn sie sich nicht
wohlfühlen einige Kehren sogar um ohne
etwas zu tun aber die bekommen dann
später Probleme wenn der Serdar Schwäche
in uns sieht wird er sich in Kathmandu
beschweren und sagen wir würden unsere
Arbeit nicht verrichten und simulieren
dann bekommen wir keine Einstellung mehr
die ersten Mitglieder der Schweizer
Expedition kommen im fertig aufgebauten
Lager 2 an die sharepas heißen sie
freundlich mit heißem Tee willkommen
im materialzelt macht Norbu Inventar
das ist acht Stück für dich
wie viele Gaskartuschen 46 Stück
mammutseile 11 mm wie viele
unter anderem stehen 50 Flaschen mit
lebenswichtigen Sauerstoff für den
Transport in weitere Hochlage bereit
ich muss die Karabiner kontrollieren ich
dachte wir werden genug davon ich habe
fünf wie viel stehen auf der Liste lass
uns die Zelte aufräumen und das Gepäck
der Mitglieder in einem anderen Zelt
abstellen dann ist unsere Arbeit für
heute zu Ende
jetzt wäre alles bereit um die weiteren
Hochlager einzurichten
die Expeditionsmitglieder Patricks Bruhn
und Meinrad bitte sind wieder ins
Basislager abgestiegen sie übernachten
nicht wie die anderen im Lager 2 die
beiden sind beeindruckt was die schärpas
Leisten
mit 50-60 Kilo Kerosin diese prüf jetzt
kommt zwei und wieder der ist
unglaublich meine 60 Kilo vor 5000 300
auf 6 30 400 Meter jeden Tag und nachher
wieder
dann folgt ein wettereinbruch er hindert
die scherbas daran weiter zu arbeiten
sie sitzen im Basislager fest mit jedem
Tag warten steigt der Druck wenn das
Wetter wieder schön wird müssen Sie
doppelt zupacken
es kann sein dass wir am 6 starten
können oder am 4 aber dann ist sehr viel
schärferkraft nötig
harte Arbeit um schnell nach oben zu
kommen harte Arbeit von jedem Scherber
wenn das passiert brauche ich euren
Power manchmal braucht ihr mein Geld
manchmal brauche ich euren Power okay
[Applaus]
das sind wirklich viel stärker als
Westler
wir sind von Geburt an an Berge gewöhnt
das ist vererbt
ity
aber noch etwas treibt die Leute an das
Geld
Expeditionsteilnehmer Patricks Bruhn hat
sich während der Wartezeit in die
Geschichte der scherbas eingelesen
das ist ein Buch über die Geschichte der
Schapers von Judy und Tashi Tensing Haut
das Shared to get into the mount wie das
Volk der scherpers in die Berge kam als
Träger und Bergführer
am Schluss gibt es eine Liste mit allen
Sherpas die auf dem Everest warnen da
habe ich dann dich Lambo oder London
gibt wo du drauf stehst
nein
was ist heute der Rekord
17 Mal der zweite ist Tom Lima
und dann
ja er war 13 mal oben
wie oft warst du denn oben
ich war auf 8.600 8700 und bin dann
immer wieder mit den Teilnehmern
umgekehrt
[Musik]
wenn ich es dieses mal schaffe schreibe
ich einen Artikel
denn ich begann als Küchenjunge würde
sehr da und habe etliche 8000er
bestiegen meine 11000 experience not on
the Airbus zu einem thinking about this
wie alt bist du jetzt 29 und du 42
wir sind wirklich sehr sehr glücklich
Schäfers für euch beide bei uns zu haben
dankeschön
ich habe ein sehr gutes Gefühl mit euch
zwei
wir sind auch sehr glücklich so starke
Mitglieder wie euch zu haben
endlich können die Arbeiten am Everest
weitergehen 15 starke schärpas aus den
verschiedenen Expeditionsteams machen
sich auf den Weg
in der nächsten Tagen werden sie in
mehreren Etappen vom Camp 2 auf 6.400
Meter bis auf den Gipfel auf
8.850 Meter Seile fixieren
alle scherbas der großen Expeditionen
arbeiten hier zusammen
es ist eine überaus gefährliche Arbeit
die sie hier verrichten im über 45 Grad
steilen vereisten Gelände der
lotseflanke
es sind viele junge schärpas dabei die
technisch versiert sind und jeden
Handgriff beherrschen
geh ein bisschen zur Seite
ja ja okay da haben wir eine Spalte
gesehen die wollen wir vermeiden
[Musik]
die seilmannschaft verlegt Meta um Meter
Seil an denen sich in ein paar Tagen
hunderte von zahlenden Gästen hochziehen
und sichern werden
[Applaus]
gegen Abend ist die Mannschaft die die
Seile in der lotseflanke fixiert hat
zurück eine weitere Gruppe von Sherpas
macht sich bereit für die nächste Etappe
auf 7.900 Meter die Sherpas aller
Expeditionen organisieren sich
selbstständig untereinander und teilen
die Gruppen ein es sind 16 Leute
lasst es uns in zwei Gruppen machen eine
muss den Gipfel einrichten davon zwei
von CARE Kobler von Kobler und Partner
ist long dodgy dabei
auch die Schweizer Expeditionsteilnehmer
sind ins Lager zwei nachgerückt die
Küchenmannschaft ist damit beschäftigt
für sich und die Schweizer Gäste das
Abendessen zuzubereiten viel Flüssigkeit
ist die Grundlage für eine gute
Akklimatisation
die Expeditionsteilnehmer lassen es sich
gut gehen und erholen sich bevor sie zum
ersten Mal ins Lager 3 aufsteigen dieses
muss von Norbu und seinen Leuten aber
zuerst aufgestellt werden
vom Basislager aus koordiniert
Expeditionsleiter karikobler die
Arbeiten und schaut dass der Zeitplan
eingehalten wird
Cam 2 von Charlie Antworten okay perfekt
wie geht es mit Lager 3
sie sind auf dem halben Weg ins Lager 3
und fixieren die Seile heute Abend
werden Sie Lager Dreier reichen und
morgen früh brechen auch wir auf
okay okay wer geht morgen ins Lager 3
ich Wang zu und insgesamt also vier
Schapers
okay dann schicken wir auch die
Teilnehmer sie sollen dort übernachten
nein übermorgen können sie ins Lager 3
keine gute Idee wenn ihr morgen früh die
Zelte aufbaut sollte es gehen
[Musik]
wir schauen morgen
versucht es
aber
es läuft nichts wir müssen alles machen
wir sind wie leiternd für die Teilnehmer
wir bauen die Sprossen und sie erreichen
den Gipfel nur über diese Sprossen
transportiert morgen mit seinem Team
Material ins Lager 3 auf 7.300 Meter
wären dorti weitere Seile bis auf 7.900
Meter verlegt
dies sei einer der härtesten Tage meint
Norbu mühsam kämpfen sich die Sherpas an
den Seilen die gestern gelegt wurden die
45 Grad steile lotseflanke hoch
im Gepäck zählte Matten Kocher und
Schaufeln für Lager 3 die Anstrengung in
der immer dünner werdenden Luft ist groß
selbst die Sherpas kommen an ihre
Grenzen
einige scherpers hören nach nur einer
Expedition mit dieser Arbeit auf sie ist
physisch und mental sehr anstrengend
man braucht viel Kraft wenn man jung ist
hat man diese Kraft aber die sind Job
kann man nicht ewig machen
nach drei Stunden haben sie auf 7.300
Meter den Platz für Lager 3 erreicht
zwischen Gletscherspalten bauen Sie die
Zelte auf
lass uns hier beginnen wir können den
Schnee auf dieser Seite aufhacken
ist ein exponierter Platz die Sherpas
müssen für jedes Zelt das Eis aufhacken
und den bodenebenen auch hier fällt das
Gelände bis zu 45 Grad steil ab
inzwischen befinden sich longodgy und
sein seilteam auf über 7.500 Meter
der Held hat schwer
wir müssen das Seil hier mit einem
firnanker fixieren
wir brauchen noch etliche auf dieser
Seite
long dodgy erinnert sich nicht gern an
diese Stelle wenn das Wetter wechselt
und Schnee fällt können die steilenwände
des Everest schnell zur Todesfalle
werden vor einigen Jahren geriet
deutsche hier in den Lawine und hat nur
mit viel Glück überlebt
ich habe viele Unfälle gesehen
Freunde von mir sind am Everest
gestorben einige sogar vor meinen Augen
Leute wurden von Lawinen mitgerissen
vielen Gletscherspalten viele solche
Unfälle
wie fühlst du dich wenn du daran denkst
sagen
ich möchte weinen ein Freund von mir
starb hier vor meinen Augen auch einige
die im gleichen Feld schliefen hat es
erwischt wenn ich daran denke möchte ich
niemals hier rauf und nie mehr diesen
Job verrichten
aber ich bin gezwungen zu arbeiten doch
ist schmerzt wenn man daran denkt
weit weg in dortis Heimatdorf Tammo geht
das Leben seinen gewohnten Gang dort ist
Ehefrau passantiki hat die
Kartoffelstauden auf dem Feld vor dem
Haus sie hat kein Telefon und weiß nicht
wie es ihrem Mann am Everest geht
kümmere mich um die Kartoffeln gieße die
knoblauchstauden jede Unkraut putze den
Garten lauter solche Arbeiten wenn
deutsche Weg ist in den Bergen das ist
meine Arbeit im Moment
jeden Passanten der vorbeikommt fragt
sie ob er Neuigkeiten vom Everest bringe
wenn nicht bittet sie ihn sie doch
sofort zu informieren wenn er etwas hört
[Musik]
und alles gut geht ich bin so glücklich
nach seiner Rückkehr wenn das Wetter
schlecht wird gehen mir viele Dinge
durch den Kopf
um sich zu beruhigen praktiziert
passanteki Jahrhunderte alte Rituale sie
präpariert reichsbier das kaltgestellt
wird bislang dirty vom Berg zurückkommt
und das erste Glas trinkt ihr Glaube
gibt ihr Kraft
eine Wirbel
wir gehen zum charakkloster in der Nähe
um zu beten einige Tage bevor sie den
Gipfel in Angriff nehmen das letzte Mal
brachte ich reißbier ins Kloster
dann beten wir erneut im Kloster und
führen das kangsur-ritual durch
[Musik]
longodgy sowie hunderte von Sherpas
andere Expeditionen transportieren nun
die lebenswichtigen Sauerstoffflaschen
für den Gipfeltag ins Lager 4 auf
7.900 Meter
[Musik]
für viele dieser scherpers ist es das
wichtigste Einkommen mit dem sie ihre
Familien in Ehren können vor allem für
die Eltern
dieser scherper einer anderen Expedition
trägt zwölf Sauerstoffflaschen also etwa
42 Kilogramm auf
7.900 Meter hoch
woher die Kraft nimmt kann niemand
nachvollziehen
die Schweizer Bergsteiger genießen den
Luxus des fertig eingerichteten Lagers 3
freust du dich auf den Berg
ich fühle mich großartig weil die
schärfers großartige Arbeit geleistet
haben
die fickseile und alles andere ihrer
bereits man muss nur dem Seil folgen und
ins Zelt sitzen du bist also zufrieden
mit dem sherpatine
sie sind hervorragend
und Johnny der ohne Sauerstoff auf den
Gipfel will
du hast schon 6 8000er bestiegen
was ist der Unterschied zum Everest das
ist der höchste
Verkehr
bei anderen Expeditionen trifft man 20
Leute hier 200 bis 300
man muss sich daran gewöhnen dann geht
es
macht dir nichts aus nein es ist normal
im Pulk und in der Kälte kämpfen sich
ihre schärpers weiter voran
heute sind es zu viele Leute
man kann die Bergsteiger fast nicht
überholen
einige laufe schnell andere langsam es
stockt es wäre einfacher wenn alle
marschieren würden aber so ist das
Laufen völlig des organisiert
nach fünf Stunden erreichen die ersten
schärpers von Cari Kobler das Lager 4
auf 7.900 Metern sie besetzen eine
Lagerplatz der bonieren ihre Lasten
darunter 50 Sauerstoffflaschen diese
versehen Sie vorsichtshalber mit einem
Schloss in der Todeszone traut man
niemandem mehr
hat es endlich geschafft im Pulk muss
der immer wieder warten und hat viel
Energie verbraucht
ich bin heute zum ersten Mal auf dem
südsuttel einige es sind schon wieder
zurückgegangen ich deponiere hier die
Sauerstoffflaschen und andere Sachen
drei Freunde sind noch hinter mir es ist
etwas windig Nebel kommt auf aber es ist
immer noch okay nicht gefährlich alles
ist noch gut
so schnell wie möglich machen sie sich
wieder auf den Abstieg ihre Arbeit ist
nun getan alles ist eingerichtet und
bereit für den Gipfelsturm
die Natur am Everest ist fantastisch
aber auch gefähr
[Musik]
lich Norbu und die anderen Sherpas sind
glücklich nach all den harten Tagen
wieder heil im Basislager einzutreffen
würde mir jetzt meine Freundin helfen
mein Gepäck im Zelt zu verstauen aber
hier bin ich alleine ich muss alles
selber erledigen mein gepäckschleppen
das ist wie eine ein Mann Armee
die Kleider müssen gewaschen werden
stinken sie
keine Frage meine Füße besonders selbst
Fische würden sterben wenn ich sie ins
Wasser hielte giftige Abfall
das dabei
jetzt müssen wir nur noch die Teilnehmer
auf den Gipfel bringen wir warten auf
diesen Tag
für den Gipfelsturm bekommt jetzt jeder
Bergsteiger seinen persönlichen scherper
zugeteilt der ihn während des Aufstiegs
zum Gipfel begleitet
okay
patrick ist mit lambodschi fertig
dein Pitch mit dem Narbe dein Richard
wangschuh
and Gianni ja versucht solche Menschen
so gut eigentlich so dass so gute
Menschen geht Gianni und der Richard
könnte vom Motor sowieso oder nachher
miteinander und der Wang zu recht gut
englisch ist technisch superstarch und
der Mengen ist einfach auch alone
was auch beim Abstieg in Anspruch nehmen
können dieses Mal sind alle Bergsteiger
stark aber oft ist dies nicht der Fall
mit einem schwachen Teilnehmer musst du
bei schlechtem Wetter immer den
Karabiner einhängen du musst dem Wasser
geben immer musst du die Handschuhe
ausziehen
das Risiko zu verunglücken ist viel
größer wenn der Teilnehmer schwach ist
manchmal macht es den schärper richtig
aggressiv wenn er mit einem schwachen
unterwegs ist
aber wir dürfen es nicht zeigen wir sind
dafür bezahlt im Basecamp können wir mit
unseren Freunden dann darüber reden aber
nicht mit den Teilnehmern
dann instruiert Kari Kobler seine
Teilnehmer über den Umgang mit
Sauerstoff denn die Luft auf 8000 Meter
ist so dünn dass der Mensch durch
Sauerstoffmangel höhenkrank werden und
daran sterben kann
ohne Sauerstoff aufsteigen aus
bergsteigerischem Ehrgeiz will er alle
8000er ohne Sauerstoff bezwingen
einfach ausgeschaltet ist was was
regelmäßig passiert will es hannözi das
einen Teilnehmer konkurriskieren wo
einfach irgendwie
früh morgens rezitiert japanovo in
seinem Zelt im Basislager die mandras
figuro-ring proced der große Tantra
Meister soll ihm beim Gipfelsturm helfen
und ihn beschützen
[Musik]
um 4 Uhr morgens machen sich die
Schweizer Expeditionsteilnehmer auf den
Weg in den Kumbo Eisfall begleitet von
sherpapa Kamera Leuten
auch Johnny und Richard montieren Ihre
Steigeisen
ihr wollt den Everest ohne Sauerstoff
besteigen
wir versuchen es ohne Sauerstoff
wir sehen wie weit wir kommen vielleicht
auf den Gipfel
es wird sehr schwierig aber wir
versuchen es
ich hoffe auf den Gipfel zu kommen ohne
Sauerstoff
Johnny und Richard verabschieden sich
Gianni weiß nicht dass es ein
endgültiger Abschied ist sein Traum alle
8000er ohne Sauerstoff zu bezwingen wird
tragisch enden
einmal mehr gehen jetzt alle Bergsteiger
und Sherpas durch den Combo eiswald
[Musik]
es ist Mitte Mai die meisten Everest
Besteigungen finden in dieser Zeit kurz
vor dem hereinbrechen des Monsuns statt
dann sind Wind und Wetter besonders
günstig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
früh morgens am zweiten Tag zieht die
Schweizer Expedition los Richtung
lotseflanke
mit dabei die speziell ausgebildeten
kameraschepers welche diese
einzigartigen Bilder liefern und in den
folgenden Tagen die Geschichte der
Expedition bis auf den Gipfel des
Everest dokumentieren werden
Winde mit über 60 Stundenkilometern
Peitschen über die eisige lotseflanke
[Musik]
in Lager 3 auf 7.300 Meter ist für die
westlichen Bergsteiger wie immer alles
bereit Zelt Matten Gaskocher Schlafsack
[Musik]
die Sherpas bleiben heute im Lager 2 und
kontrollieren ein letztes Mal die neuen
Sauerstoffmasken
der Sauerstoff ist jetzt auf Level 25
die Nadel geht zurück wenn der
Sauerstoff aufgebraucht wird sie geht
auf Null wenn der Zähler zwischen 0 und
5 ist müsste die Flasche auswechseln
habt ihr das verstanden
das ist null passt bitte auf
sind für den Sauerstoff verantwortlich
wir haben alle Masken kontrolliert
manchmal stößt man auf eine defekte
Maske wenn man sie auf dem südsattel
braucht deshalb wollen wir sie schon
hier unten ganz genau kontrollieren
Lager 3 hat Expeditionsleiter karik
Kobler eben die neuesten Wetterdaten aus
der Schweizer halten
jetzt gibt es sie per Funk an Norbu im
Lager 2 weiter
NABU du kannst jetzt die
Wettervorhersage dem seil-team
weiterleiten
bis Mitternacht gibt es noch wins
gegen Morgen Mittag wird es windstill
dafür nimmt die Bewölkung zu aber in der
Nacht sollte es wieder sehr schön sein
am 21 um Mittag könnte es etwas
Schneefall geben leichte Niederschläge
aber kein Wind bis am 22
[Musik]
6 Uhr morgens am nächsten Tag die
Sherpas steigen heute direkt vom Lager 2
ins Lager 4 hoch aber sie haben sich
verschlafen es ist schon 6 Uhr wir
wollten eigentlich um 5 Uhr losziehen
hätte ich meine Freunde nicht geweckt
würden sie immer noch pennen Sam tief
geschlafen weiß nicht warum weil es so
schön warm war
verspätet laufen sie los was Folgen
haben wird
im Lager 3 brechen inzwischen die
Teilnehmer Richtung südsattel auf
[Musik]
als die Sherpas schließlich im Lager 3
eintreffen erwartet Sie eine böse
Überraschung einige Bergsteiger haben
ihre Schlafsäcke und Matten liegen
lassen da nicht klar abgesprochen war
wer die Last mitnehmen soll nun müssen
die schärpers zusätzliches Gewicht
schleppen
wie viel Sauerstoffflaschen hast du okay
wir nehmen alle drei ich eine und geh
nur eine die dritte geben wir Angst
pember lackbar oder niemanden du
keiner ist begeistert von
7.300 auf 7.900 Meter noch mehr Material
mitzutragen Norbu ist wütend
vergeudet nicht eure Zeit packt das
Gepäck und lasst uns hochklettern Trödel
dich länger rum pack dein Gepäck das ist
ein Job und morgen morgen werden wir
mehr Geld verlangen
wir müssen es mitnehmen es bringt nichts
wenn wir streiten die Teilnehmer sind
schon weg während wir rechtzeitig
gegangen hätten wir die Teilnehmer
getroffen und das anders verteilen
können aber ihr habt ihr alle verpennt
sonst hätten wir das mit Kari besprechen
können aber der ist ja auch schon weg ja
die sind alle weg
[Musik]
statt wie vorgesehen zwölf Kilo schleppt
jeder schärper jetzt mindestens 26 Kilo
welche als letzte los steigen
trotzdem holen die ersten Sherpas ihre
Bergsteiger am Genf versporn auf 7.600
Meter ein
[Musik]
Johnny ruht sich aus er will seine
Kräfte schonen
bist du okay ja okay ich brauche die
Energie für morgen gute Leute
weiter unten in der Masse kämpfen Norbu
und die anderen Sherpas in der dünnen
Luft die Sonne brennt die Temperatur
liegt bei 0 Grad
jedermannslast ist schwer heute die
persönlichen Sachen der Teilnehmer
gegen 13 Uhr erreichen die Schweizer
Bergsteiger den südsattel auf 7.900
Meter das letzte Hochlager vor dem
Gipfel die Anspannung ist groß
Norbu hingegen befindet sich immer noch
im Aufstieg
mit ihrem schweren Gepäck kommen die
sharepas nur mühsam voran
[Musik]
es ist ein schwieriger Job heute den
jeder von uns trägt 25 bis 26 Kilo die
Teilnehmer haben alles zurückgelassen
sie tragen nur ihre Unterhosen den
daunenanzug und einen kleinen Rucksack
so schweres Gepäck zwischen 7.300 und
7.900 Meter zu tragen das ist hart
einige brauchen zusätzlich Sauerstoff
aber es ist trotzdem ein sehr
schwieriger Job
doch man vergisst alles wenn man wieder
zurück im Basecamp ist natürlich
wir dürfen uns aber all diese
Schwierigkeiten nicht anmerken lassen
wir müssen immer eine fröhliche Mine
aufsetzen aber da kann man nichts machen
das ist die Natur dieses Jobs
[Musik]
nach über acht Stunden Aufstieg wird
NABU von Expeditionsleiter karik Kobler
im Lager 4 begrüßt
bist du müde nein nein nicht so sehr
sehr gut
das ganze Gepäck ist jetzt oben
kello Sherpa hat sich am Funk beklagt
dann habe ich ihm gesagt wenn du am Funk
sprechen kannst kannst du auch klettern
die westlichen Bergsteiger entspannen
sich und probieren wieder zu Kräften zu
kommen speziell Johnny der ohne
Sauerstoff auf den Gipfel will müsste
sich hier gut regenerieren aber er wirkt
müde
es war heute lang und hart
wo ist
[Musik]
wir begannen nicht so früh aber es waren
viele Leute wir mussten oft warten
langsam
[Musik]
ich habe mir einen Sonnenbrand geholt
ich bin in der Mittagssonne stecken
geblieben konnte nicht gehen und so
komme ich erst jetzt
nun die 50 Sauerstoffflaschen
untereinander auf
ein Teilnehmer bekommt vier
Sauerstoffflaschen eine kann das schon
im Lager drei brauchen oder auf dem
südsattel drei bleiben dann auch übrig
sie werden einem beim Aufstieg benutzen
und wir tragen die anderen zwei eine ist
Reserve eine weitere benützen wir alles
in allem tragen wir also vier Flaschen
wir starten um 10 Uhr abends alles ist
jetzt bereit nun können wir uns drei bis
vier Stunden ausruhen die Jungs werden
das Essen und Trinken und danach etwas
schlafen mitten in der Nacht geht es
dann los
es brennt so
der abgekochte Tee wird zum Gipfel
mitgenommen
heute war es wirklich schwierig willst
du nicht aufhören
aber dann ist da auch die Vorfreude auf
den Gipfel und das ist mein erstes Mal
ich habe Kopfweh diesen Job kann man
nicht aufgeben das Geld
es wird eine kurze Ruhepause zu dritt
oder zu viert in einem Zelt versuchen
Sie sich zu entspannen
[Musik]
Sauerstoff um sich besser zu erholen
nur noch zwei Stunden ich will mich
etwas ausruhen
20 Mai
2008 Vollmond
10 Uhr
narbo ist der erste der aus dem Zelt
kriegt
Charlie alles okay
guten Morgen
alles okay alles okay die Sherpas
kontrollieren ein letztes Mal die
Sauerstoffflaschen
Level 2 nein Level 3 ist gut
auch die schärpers Benutzen von nun an
Sauerstoffgeräte
warte
das musst Du besser anziehen hier
zuerst hier unten und dann da musst Du
hier oben ziehen
wie ist meine Sauerstoffflasche
eingestellt
aber das ist gut
also mein Freund
viel Glück
[Musik]
und dann marschieren sie los ziemlich
ihre Stirnlampen die ganze Nacht
hindurch
[Musik]
über 100 Alpinisten wollen in dieser
Nacht auf dem Gipfel aller Gipfel
[Musik]
johnny ist bereits eine Stunde vor den
anderen aufgebrochen da ohne Sauerstoff
langsamer läuft auf etwa 8.400 Meter
unter dem berghony Überholen sie hier
wechseln die anderen Teilnehmer ihre
ersten Sauerstoffflaschen
[Musik]
um 5 Uhr morgens erreichen Sie den
Südgipfel die Verhältnisse sind gut aber
jeder Schritt schmerzt
die Sherpas sichern Ihre Gäste wenn die
Kraft auf 8.700 Meter ausgeht
[Musik]
auch longodgy leidet in dieser Höhe
tief unten liegt das Hochland von Tibet
[Musik]
nur gerade 90 Höhenmeter unter dem
Gipfel liegt das letzte stallstück der
Hillary step benannt nach dem erstbegehr
des Everest Sir Edmund Hillary
dann ist es geschafft
kurz vor 9 Uhr morgens stehen die
Expeditionsteilnehmer von karikobler auf
dem höchsten Gipfel der Welt dem Mount
Everest auf
8.850 Metern über dem Meeresspiegel
danke Jesus
okay
[Musik]
danke mein bester Freund Patrick
wir haben es geschafft
[Musik]
das Schweizer bergsteigerteam ist vor
ihren Sherpas auf dem Gipfel die noch im
Stau stecken
[Musik]
auch für die Sherpas hat es geklappt
Norbu steht zum ersten Mal auf dem Dach
der Welt er entfaltet seine Gebetsfahnen
um den Göttern zu danken für die ist es
das 14 Mal
lass die nepal-flagge über dem höchsten
Berg der Welt flattern Sieg für Nepal
gucken
es war seit vier Jahren mein Traum seit
vier Jahren versuche ich auf den Mount
Everest zu klettern dieser Traum hat
sich erfüllt ich bin hocherfolgt
[Musik]
in den letzten vier Jahren vom Norden
und vom Süden ausprobiert jetzt bin ich
auf dem höchsten Berg der Welt mit Hilfe
meiner Freunde
flattern im Wind ich fühle mich nahe bei
Gott
bin überglücklich
ich werde diesen Moment nie vergessen
[Musik]
wie fühlt es sich an zum 14 Mal auf dem
everesto ich bin so glücklich nicht nur
ich viele meiner schärfer-freunde sind
zum ersten Mal hier
wie viele Schärfe sind wir hier acht
von acht ist es für Sex das erste Mal
dank true und ich waren schon hier oben
es ist großartig eine tolle Leistung Sex
neue Everest besteigen und fast alle
Expeditionsteilnehmer sind auch hier ich
bin so glücklich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach einer knappen Stunde auf dem Gipfel
bereiten Sie Sherpas und Teilnehmer auf
den Abstieg vor
jetzt
gib mir viel Sauerstoff den brauche ich
für den Abstieg ich brauche Power
allerdings
[Musik]
alle waren oben bis auf journey der ohne
Sauerstoff immer noch unterwegs ist
auf 8.760 Meter direkt am Hillary step
treffen sie auf ihn unschärferingma
auf dem
Hillary step im Aufstieg ich habe ihn
gefragt wie es ihm geht er sagte okay
ich dachte es ist nicht mehr weit bis
zum Gipfel und Minga hat Sauerstoff für
den Rückweg dabei ich hatte ein gutes
Gefühl wenn Janni auf den Gipfel kommt
das wäre wunderbar ich sah kein Problem
da Gianni ja mit Sauerstoff hätte
absteigen können aber im Nachhinein war
es ein Fehler
Gianni und sein Sherpa erreichen um 10
Uhr den Gipfel Gianni macht Fotos alles
scheint gut
die übrigen Expeditionsmitglieder sind
inzwischen im Lager 4 angekommen
gezeichnet von über 14 Stunden Kletterei
in dünner Luft
[Musik]
Schichtung
auf dem Gipfel gewesen zu sein
wir waren fast die ersten auf dem Gipfel
es war überwältigend
wir kamen zurück ins Lager 4 begannen
Eis zu schmelzen und Wasser zu kochen
nach kurzer Pause steigen sie ins Lager
2 auf 6.400 Meter ab dorthin wo die Luft
mit Meer Sauerstoff gesättigt ist auch
long dodgy ist dabei
[Musik]
in diesem Moment bekamen wir einen
Funkspruch das mit Johnny etwas nicht
stimmt auch unser Bruder Ming war sei in
Schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
Johnny beginnt auf dem Gipfel plötzlich
zu schwanken und zu halluzinieren
[Musik]
Schmerzen in der Brust er konnte nicht
mehr gehen und ich musste ihn hinunter
schleppen
an schwierigen Stellen ging ich vor und
half ihm runter es war unglaublich
schwierig ich dachte jetzt wird er
sterben
[Musik]
denen wir begegneten um eine
Sauerstoffmaske
sich wie ein Verrückter
vielleicht wusste er dass er sterben
könnte
ich hatte ihm seine eigene Maske gegeben
aber die zerstörte er mit seiner Hand
ich wollte ihm meine Maske geben aber
die wollte er nicht
weiter vorbei an aufsteigenden
Bergsteigern
um 15.30 Uhr brechen Shepherd Andy und
der deutsche Arzt Richard Brill vom
Lager 4 mit mehr Sauerstoff und weiteren
Medikamenten auf und gehen ihnen
entgegen
[Musik]
Marsch lebt Johnny weiter sie sind
inzwischen 20 Stunden ohne Pause
unterwegs
steil
ich konnte Johnny kaum mehr tragen
ich dachte vielleicht sterbe ich jetzt
auch
vielleicht sterben wir beide wenn das
Seil reist es war sehr hart als wir
beide an diesem Seil hängen so brachte
ich Johnny runter
um 21 Uhr in der Nacht treffen der
deutsche Arzt Richard Brill und Sherpa
denn die auf Gianni und Mingo
was in dem Channel genau vorgegangen ist
weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur dass wir ihn
eigentlich dann am Balkon eigentlich um
9 Uhr Abends getroffen haben
dass er ansprechbar war dass etwas
unterkühlt war das ein bisschen
dehydriert war aber das ist ihm
eigentlich für die Umstände für meine
Sichtweise relativ
gut ging und dass wir ihn dann eben
versucht haben vom Balkon aus
runterzubringen Richtung Südpol
Gianni bekommt weitere Medikamente und
Sauerstoff sie scheinen zu wirken
scherba denn die löst mingma ab
langsam Schritt für Schritt runter
ich ging vor ihm plötzlich stoppte er
ich musste uns an dieser Position
sichern als ich das tat Risse mir das
Seil aus der Hand
ich war über seine plötzliche
Veränderung sehr überrascht
etwas von der gesicherten Position Weg
in der wir uns befanden ich konnte ihn
gerade noch auffangen als ich das tat
war Johnny bereits tot ich schüttelte
ihn und schrie seinen Namen ich sagte
Johnny komm wir müssen weiter
aber er war tot ich war schockiert in
diesem Moment es war das erste Mal in
meinem Leben dass ich einen Menschen in
den Bergen sterben sah nie zuvor starb
ein Mensch vor meinen Augen
eine Gruppe von Sherpas bringt Giannis
Leiche auf den südsattel
scherperming meist gezeichnet
fast 30 Stunden war er ohne Pause im
Einsatz
ich bin sehr aufgewühlt in diesem Moment
sich ich möchte nie mehr in die Berge
gehen ich möchte meinen Job aufgeben
aber ich habe keine Alternativen
ich muss arbeiten um meine Familie zu
unterhalten ich muss arbeiten
wie lange willst du noch in den Bergen
arbeiten
[Musik]
dann will ich aufhören es ist genug auch
meine Frau will dass ich nicht mehr in
den Bergen arbeite
die Expedition geht weiter die sharepass
brechen das Lager 4 ab
auch Cari geht Richtung Basislager er
hat bis jetzt hier ausgeharrt und alles
koordiniert
[Musik]
unten im Basislager treffen die
Teilnehmer nach ihrem Gipfelerfolg ein
erst in der Nacht haben sie verfunk von
Giannis Tod erfahren
[Musik]
die versuchen den Tod von Gianni zu
verstehen
der menschlichen
und
ich komme mit dem Johnny Stunde aber das
Diskutieren und ich selber Böden
wenigstens hat immer wieder
so wie andere wie das Vorspiele als
Religion alle irgendwie so oder so
sondern er hätte eigentlich sich immer
ein gewisses Spiel drin offen
und
vielleicht ist es sogar das Opfer
verschiedene eigene verschiedene eigene
Kraft
nicht
was ich natürlich
das ist
so nicht
April
s steigen am anderen Tag noch einmal auf
7.900 Meter auf sie wollen Gianni nicht
wie viele andere tote am Everest einfach
liegen lassen
beim Big Stone haben sie ihm aus Steinen
eine letzte Ruhestätte erbaut
während den zwei Monaten ist Jenny zu
einem Freund der scherpers geworden
lasst uns unsere Mützen ausziehen und
deine Schweigeminute einlegen
wir legen immer eine Schweigeminute ein
für jeden der stirbt
und dann verneigen wir uns vor ihm
wir müssen beten wir können uns nicht
ohne Gebet von ihm verabschieden
auf der Gegenseite des everestamphumori
errichten die Expeditionsteilnehmer zur
gleichen Zeit eine Gedenkstätte zu Ehren
ihres bergsteigerkollegen
[Musik]
die Trauer und der Respekt sind groß
der liebenswürdige Gianni wird allen in
Erinnerung bleiben
das ist ein sehr trauriger Moment für
uns
denn wir verabschieden uns von unserem
Expeditionsteilnehmer Gianni
wir lassen ihn hier zurück auf dem
südsattel
er war für uns nicht nur ein Teilnehmer
sondern ein guter Freund
hier ist er hat uns unterstützt er war
nett liebenswert und freundlich
er stand uns nah
mit Guss
dieser Moment ist sehr traurig
das ist alles was ich sagen wollte leb
wohl
vorbei
Gianni ist der 211 tote am Everest ist
der einzige im Jahr 2008 in welchem 290
Menschen auf dem Gipfel standen
die Expedition neigt sich dem Ende zu
die schärpers transportieren alles
Material aus den Hochlagern wieder ins
Basislager die Zeiten als der Everest
wie eine Müllhalde aussah sind vorbei
alles was hier hochkommt muss heute
wieder runtergebracht werden
trifft nach dem 14 Gipfelerfolg im
Basecamp ein
[Applaus]
wie oft will er noch auf den Everest
gehen
darüber habe ich noch nicht nachgedacht
ich arbeite solange ich mag
aber ich muss nicht unbedingt noch mal
so viele Male auf den Gipfel
ich arbeite solange ich physisch dazu in
der Lage bin
trotz aller Gefahr ist der Everest ein
lukratives Geschäft
die
Opfern uns für die harte Arbeit am Berg
auf wenn wir im Basislager ankommen
probieren wir den Schmerz und die
Schwierigkeiten zu vergessen
am nächsten Tag laufen wir nach Hause
und denken dass wir diese Arbeit nie
mehr machen werden aber dann kommen wir
in einem Jahr wieder ins Basislager und
erinnern uns nicht mehr an all die
Anstrengungen und alles geht wieder von
vorne los
[Musik]
Jackson Träger transportieren das
umfangreiche Material der Expedition
zurück nach Lukla
auch unsere sharepas brechen auf in der
Tasche je nach Leistung 4.500 bis 5.500
Dollar gutes Geld und viel home den Sie
nutzen können
wenn ich diese Kleider anziehe dann sehe
ich gut aus und dann freue ich mich auf
den Heimweg auf die Ladies und das gute
Essen
jetzt denke ich acht oder neun Monate
nicht mehr in den Everest man braucht
auch Zeit für die Frauen
Bergdorf Tamo wo er wieder zum einfachen
Bauern wird
wie jeden Tag geht seine Frau zur Arbeit
hinaus auf die Felder sie weiß nicht
wann deutsche heimkehrt
[Musik]
so erwartet den Everest Helden zu Hause
eine herbe Überraschung
besteht vor
verschlossener Tür
das ist das Geschäft der shephers
Anstrengung Gefahr gutes Geld und Erfolg
alles im Schatten des Everest
[Musik]